et ce sera l'occasion pour le japon de
se repositionner sur le marché des
technologies de pointe après une
décennie de récession aujourd'hui le
soleil du futur technologique se lèvent
de nouveau à l'est et les firmes
japonaises paraît sur les robots
humanoïdes
oui on est encore loin de la machine
douée d'intelligence et remplaçant
l'homme mais vous allez le voir la
ressemblance avec nos petits frères
d'acier ferait presque froide en douce
et le dossier du soir 3 et décider
claude guaino et jean christophe duclos
a inventé des robots pour remplacer
l'homme sur les chaînes de montage cela
fait une trentaine d'années que
l'industrie automobile c'est le faire
mais un robot qui ressemble à un être
humain
le défi est plus difficile à relever il
s'appelle à 6 mo mais il est vrai qu'il
a encore beaucoup de chemin à faire pour
avoir des airs d'humanoïdes et pourtant
derrière son look de cosmonautes à simo
a franchi une étape considérable
c'est le premier robot qui peut marcher
véritablement éviter des obstacles
courir descendre des escaliers
il peut même effectuer certaines tâches
comme serré des boulons simonet c'est un
robot qui est destiné à être utile dans
la vie il ne peut pas remplacer
entièrement l'être humain mais il peut
effectuer certaines tâches à leur place
et nous ne sommes qu'au début de nos
recherches pas dans ce laboratoire de
l'université des sciences de tokyo ces
chercheurs étudient le système
musculaire
il tente de reproduire les mouvements du
corps pour les intégrer dans le
programme informatique qui pilote le
robot et c'est au cours de leurs
recherches qu'ils se sont pas bien su
qu'il pouvait aussi concevoir des
vêtements prothèse capables d'assister
les personnes ayant des difficultés
motrices
notre but est de faire des systèmes
utile pour les gens au japon il ya
d'énormes besoins de la part des
personnes âgées ou handicapées nos
robots pourront développer des fonctions
spécifiques comme aider les gens à se
déplacer à se nourrir
sous ce masque de silicone tout un
système de ressort et le tendeur pour
reproduire une apparence humaine
mais pour le professeur kobayashi et ses
étudiants le robot est plus qu'un
automate
il doit être doué d'une certaine forme
d'intelligence artificielle comprendre
ce qu'on lui dit exprimer des émotions
et des sentiments
je suis en train de calculer la
résistance des muscles de la face
pour l'instant les mouvements du visage
sont encore trop faibles pour donner une
expression à ce visage l'aboutissement
provisoire est encore imparfait de ses
recherches c'est sayah en démonstration
dans le hall d'accueil de l'université
grâce à un système de reconnaissance
vocale sayah parle et renseigne les
visiteurs
elle peut même sourire ou ceux montrés
étonnés si le japon s'intéresse autant
aux robots c'est évidemment parce qu'il
a les compétences en électronique et en
informatique
mais il est également poussée par sa
démographie sa population vieillit sa
population diminue c'est pourquoi le
japon est à la recherche de toutes les
solutions qui lui permettront de
remplacer l'être humain